every week we we touch on what's going
on in the crypto world let's do we have
the crypto world you have to crypto's
such a big thing these days you don't
want to know how big of a thing crypto
is these days how big one in 10 people
are currently investing in crypto wow so
cnbc did a survey
and here were the rankings of the most
um
utilized financial assets out there
crypto's in the top five by the way
number one real estate number two
stocks number three mutual funds number
four bonds number five crypto okay of
all the things that are out there
now if you said five ten years ago
crypto has been the top five asset
classes
no one believed you yeah crypto's out
there bro one in 10 people are investing
in crypto are you investing in crypto
yet i don't know
i got a little investment in crypto okay
and you know the top reasons they said
why people are investing in crypto well
i'll tell you the top five reasons here
they are the top reasons cited it's easy
to make trades
it's exciting to invest in
and there's potential for high growth in
a short period of time no [ __ ] there's a
lot of people out there playing the
crypto game the question is here it is
is cryptocurrency investing
or gambling
is it investing or gambling what do you
think
it is
[ __ ] sometimes it feels like it's
gambling man
elon musk with a tweet can skyrocket or
really plunge the price of a
cryptocurrency well let's talk about
that let's talk about that
let's talk about let's unpack this so
too many people believe that investing
is gambling like it's going to the
casino right yeah as it turns out
investing is not gambling my friends it
is not gambling at all is risk involved
yes
right is reward involved yes that's kind
of the you know risk and reward
investing is a game of chance well
that depends on your investing
strategy let's talk about this the
difference between investing and
gambling is
strategy yeah strategy
it's the strategy and the planning
behind the asset
which decides whether or not you're
actually investing or gambling let's
unpack that a little bit so an investor
will use tools such as diversification
to mitigate risks and decrease the
chance for loss
whereas a gambler is typically all in
bro
with a singular lever lever dictating
whether they win or lose okay they're
full tilt as they like to say yeah so
even if you hold different types of
cryptocurrency
only investing in one asset class or a
single asset class such as crypto means
you aren't mitigating risk through asset
allocation and diversification quick
example let's say you got a you know
a hundred thousand dollars let's just
let's just use an example sure 100 you
say you know what
i'm gonna put fifty 000
into the stock market mutual funds etfs
cool i'm gonna take
25 000 and i'm gonna put that as a down
payment
on a property
okay now you got 25 000 left all right
so okay cool let me put ten thousand
dollars into crypto let me keep uh ten
thousand dollars in cash
and five thousand i could literally go
gamble
like literally go game yeah sports
better i'm willing to whatever
who knows but that's asset allocation
diversification so you've got some
stocks bonds mutual funds in the in
in your
stock market exposure right you've got
some real estate exposure maybe you
don't want to buy a property you put it
into a reit cool reit real estate
investment trust you got some money in
crypto cool you got cash pay the bills
emergency fund then you take a small
percentage of it maybe five percent you
say [ __ ] it i'm gonna go gamble
been on the jets this weekend bro
we'll see they got crushed this dude
yeah last week um
but there's a game plan you're not just
100 in on crypto okay so here's the
difference between investors
and gamblers the difference between
investors and gamblers investors have
very specific goals around the rate of
return the time horizon and the risk
tolerance itself
rate of return time horizon and risk
tolerance itself gamblers
their primary goal
revolves around just winning the bet
without any additional structural
elements or constraint that's it
so the bottom line is this investor's
got a plan they got a strategy as george
w bush you used to like to say i got
strategery
i got some strategy okay but they got a
plan they got some strategy they're an
investor gambler is like
come on black
yeah right come on dogecoin yeah there's
no strategy to it you're just kind of
it's like a
hope and a prayer
anyways investors they got rate of
return time horizon risk tolerance these
are all things that they're looking into
gamblers are just throwing money and
looking in the other way so you need to
ask yourself are you investing or are
you
all we talk gambling money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken
you